c'est un endroit n'est pas créé la fois
c'était ici à central park ok allez vous
à thème du feu
[Musique]
pour avoir ce smartphone et olivier la
prod et shoot
[Musique]
ça
on a new york soleil couchant sur la
statue de la liberté
c'est juste magnifique bon au programme
du jour tester le nouveau smartphone de
crosse cole tracker x4 que je vous ai
présenté il ya quelques mois à paris
faire du vélo dans manhattan
allez le tester sur la banquise enfin un
programme de fou on était ce la nuit on
teste le jour on arrête pas et là tout
de suite
cependant je vous parle je dis a
commencé un petit moment regardez je
suis en train de faire un time lapse sur
le statut la liberté c'est juste
magnifique
de retour à new york il ya c'était la
journée de voyage du retour de las vegas
du cs plutôt bien passé c'est es juste
et donc j'ai encore plein de choses au
pubis avec cool mais aujourd'hui c'est
l'heure de vous parler du tracker x4 de
crosse colle donc on va se faire plein
de tests à new york mais première chose
à faire mais il ya peu tard je mets
profité j'ai vraiment fait la feignasse
midi le cas ça fait des années que je me
suis pas levé abidjan j'en profite en
reste et ce truc est mon avis ça va être
vachement intéressant ça smartphone
outdoor il est censé être résistant ne
pas craindre les coups aller sous l'eau
c'est ce qu'on va voir
[Musique]
du coup
certes pas trop mal marché ce truc donc
maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va les tester à l'extérieur ça c'est le
t-shirt d'une marque française que j'ai
acheté au hellfest cette année crève
j'adore ce t-shirt bon ici c'est bien
parce que personne ne comprendra que ça
veut dire d'une façon il fait 0 donc je
vais me mettre aux bulles d épaisseur
pour avoir chaud j'aime beaucoup le
packaging qu'ils ont fait pour le x tic
c'est parce qu'on sympa vous avez cette
petite trousse faut l'ouvrir brassard de
tensiomètre icloud boy qui trouvent deux
docteurs ça c'est sympa
vous avez ici le seul fils tic vous
pouvez monter super héros le petit trip
hop et là une télécommande bluetooth
qu'on peut hop actionner pour déclencher
des photos jusqu'à 40 m ok tout ça c'est
bien sympa mais tend à nous faire faire
un petit tour de ma chambre j'ai
beaucoup partagé ça avec vous la
regardez je sais assez cotisé assez
petit jeu c'est le mode sun hotels pas
loin de central park dont vous avez
vraiment petite piaule hors jeu c'est
prendre du recul on se met pas la main
vous voyez c'est la chambre tout bois à
ses causes y c'est franchement pas mal
c'est assez mignon alors la vue c'est
sur une cour intérieure donc en plus
l'écart au sprint et colas donc on y
voit absolument rien là vous voyez
directement la douche
donc quand vous êtes à deux points de
mire et le spectacle se présente pas
petit couloir par contre le problème
c'est qu'elle a aucune place pour poser
les valises moi j'ai une très grosse
valise franchement j'ai aucune place
pour la mettre ni là ni là ni là là
dedans n'en parlons absolument pas c'est
un peu la galère c'est tout petit mais
voyez moi j'ai la plus petite sont que
c'est un peu plus grand à côté
d'ailleurs ils ont fait la fête jusqu'à
3 heures du matin pas moyen de dormir
la petite salle de bain c'est assez
mignon c'est tout mignon petite salle de
bains miroir et franchement cool mais je
vous dirais la petite douche voilà c'est
assez minimaliste mais ces 3
on va tester le smartphone sur la glace
au sol
ça
vous vous demandiez comment construire
et les building
voilà vous avez la réponse tout comme
y'a pas de banquise à new york
j'ai testé ça sur la patinoire de
central park seulement comme ses parois
de filmer avec ses grands caméra j'y
vais avec les smartphones et un an j'en
ai pas fait la passe était ici à central
park
ok allez baptême du feu
[Musique]
ou alors que ce smartphone est poli très
vite la prod et shoot
[Musique]
là c'est le mode normal
là c'est le mode large
[Musique]
super large
ultra large
[Musique]
fish eye
bon la banque qui sait bien maintenant
on va continuer l'aventuré en amorçant
s'est pas écrasé en prenant un vélo
public sur new york on va descendre tout
en bas de manhattan
quand on va essayer si on arrive à qui
[Musique]
gentille ans
expo québec
[Musique]
arrivé au sud de manhattan
ça chauffe pour le pédalage ouf on
l'espère des petites photos là bas c'est
amaury dubois
regardez-moi ça soleil couchant c'est
juste magnifique ok bon bien arrivé quel
parcours des centres de central park
jusqu'ici c'est chaud enfin c'est chaud
si on veut merci aux vélos donc vous
avez un coucher de soleil
si vous allez voir au fond là bas vous
avez la statue de la liberté
[Musique]
l'homme et aux quartiers sud de
manhattan c'est là vous avez vous street
les navettes pour aller à la statue de
la liberté et le courrier juste ouf
[Musique]
à
on fait beaucoup trop froid tout de
suite là ya du vent ces écailles
on va aller continuer tout ça on va
débriefer un peu ce smartphone dans un
endroit beaucoup plus chaud
[Musique]
solana
et
t
un homme
et
[Applaudissements]
un peu
c
soit près jamais pagezy
à un retour au studio on se faire un
point sur le tracker x4 je suis hyper
partagé parce que j'aime beaucoup le
concept je trouve que c'est vraiment
bien ce qu'a fait cros cole là dessus
l'idée d'intégrer d'axione calmes sur un
smartphone outdoor c'est juste parfait
c'était juste l'idée part fait avoir
mais il y a quand même quelques
problèmes avec ce smartphone
je vous explique il se fait pas
forcément vous parlez des capteurs vous
avez sur le x4 néanmoins ça marche bien
ça vous l'avez sur d'autres smartphones
déjà de chez cros cole c'est pour moi
pas le truc le plus important sur ce
smartphone
bon c'est quand même cool je voulais
montrer très rapidement le thermomètre
l'hydrométrie la boussole accéléromètre
le baromètre l'altimètre le gps le cap à
proximité la luminosité le bluetooth le
wifi la batterie pas vous n'êtes
vraiment pas mal de choses pour lui
verse à l'extérieur faye a vraiment
beaucoup de choses ça c'est intéressant
mais le point le plus important sur ce
smartphone c'est son iphone calmes je le
répète c'est vraiment une excellente
idée qu à cros cole là dessus et ça
c'est en tant que tueur vraiment à
saluer laissez moi vous expliquer
comment ça marche dans votre application
saas est simple vous appuyer là pour
enregistrer vous appuyez ici pour faire
des photos et vous pouvez faire les deux
en même temps ça c'est assez facile donc
là vous avez plusieurs modes saas et le
mode normal
vous avez le mode large vous avez le
mode super large
vous avez le mode ultra large et ensuite
vous avez le mode fichiers
alors vous le voyez plus vous appuyez et
plus vous déformez direct mode large et
mode normal ça fonctionne dès que vous
arrivez à partir du super large tout de
suite ça déforme forcément ça de
rajouter deux langues
par contre c'est franchement efficace
bon le fisheye j'aime franchement
beaucoup moins mais tout le reste c'est
quand même hyper cool après vous pouvez
choisir d'appuyer là ça avoue le pivot
t'ai vu que vous êtes sur une caméra qui
est complètement ronde vous pouvez
choisir soit vous voulez film est à la
verticale
soit vous filmer comme ça à
l'horizontale comme vous voulez ensuite
la vous pouvez venir bloqués ici
directement votre écran ce qui fait que
vous n'avez plus accès à aucune commande
ne pouvait plus rien faire ça s'est
vraiment bien lorsque vous allez le
mettre dans l'eau ça va éviter que les
gouttes d'eau viennent vous faire des
actions ou même course que vous la tenez
comme ça vous pouvez poser votre doigt
derrière ça ne fait absolument rien
c'est bien et là vous pouvez juste
devenir déclenchée en appuyant sur le
bouton ricort sur le côté ça c'est
franchement super cool et lorsque vous
voulez sortir de ce mode là voyez il
vous suffit juste de secouer le
téléphone suffisamment fort
et à ce moment là ça va marcher à
nouveau bon pays si vous avez un petit
flash alors vous avez différentes façons
30 des photos soit version un petit peu
dynamique soit du slow motion time lapse
dash capita vous allez enregistrés dans
le passé toutes les 30 secondes ça va
couper
lorsque vous voulez récupérer quelque
chose qui vient de se passer vous
appuyez et vous remontez à 30 secondes
en arrière alors vous pouvez choisir 30
secondes 60 secondes voir un petit peu
plus comme vous voulez là c'est du live
mais uniquement sur facebook bon
pourquoi pas et l'a ensuite vous pouvez
venir un petit peu customiser tout ça
vous pouvez filmer à différents formats
full hd 2k 4k bon même hd si vous voulez
vous pouvez filmer uniquement en 30
images par seconde personnellement j'ai
filmer en full hd alors temps en temps
j'ai rencontré des problèmes là
typiquement regarder ça m'a fait ça j'ai
une espèce d'écran comme ça au début et
après ça revient alors ça me l'a fait de
temps en temps ça n'a pas fait tout le
temps cela fait sur quelques extraits ça
c'est un petit problème logiciel un
petit bug je pense que s'appelle
corriger rapidement
alors laissez-moi vous montrer je
rencontre un petit bug je pense que
c'est qu'un bug logiciel ça peut être
corrigé par exemple je vais vouloir
importer ça je fais créé x story et là
hop paysage next hockey et là j'ai mes
lectures et là j'ai le sont mais j'ai
absolument aucune image
j'ai absolument rien ça c'est un peu
embêtant par contre up ce que je fais je
vais dans and media je continue je vais
vous rajoutez par exemple un ou deux
trois médias dans le même format
hop je fais importés dans hick story
sélectionne le premier le premier ne
marche toujours pas par contre je mets
sur le deuxième le deuxième marche voilà
donc ce que ça c'est un petit bug un
petit bug logiciel c'est pas bien grave
voilà un petit peu pour ces concerts de
l'important x tories alors bon on va
dire que le premier et qui a posé le
problème
hop je lai s'appuyer dessus je le dégage
et on en parle plus maintenant lorsque
je vais faire le montage s'est pas
vraiment vraiment parfait par exemple je
me mets par là je peux venir raccourcir
le mener à cette séquence je raccourcis
je veux une séquence de vélo quand même
assez courtes dans la deuxième après
pareil on va se prendre une petite
séquence un peu courte donc là j'ai
trois séquences que j'ai mis ensuite je
sais faire and music donc je peux
choisir soit les musiques qui sont déjà
là soit venir moi qu'un porter une
musique directement dans mon catalogue
bon ça c'est au choix pour l'instant
j'en ai pas donc on va mettre une de
leur musique ça ira franchement très
bien on va se mettre électro ajouté
musique et l'achever finish etc story
donc la sacrée ça c'est un peu long je
pense que l'expérience est reçue est pas
terrible ça peut mettre de plusieurs
minutes à quelques heures ça dépend de
la longueur de votre vidéo
voilà c'est pas gg l'amérique story et
créer lecture et lassana joué en entier
bon je baisse le son parce que j'ai pas
les droits d'auteur là dessus sinon la
qualité est pas mal le truc est pas
complètement fou sauf que là la stap
pour être encore plus poussée et
lorsqu'on voit un peu à la fin naïm aux
quelques secondes et ça me met ensuite
la pub pour x calmes et ça ça m'embête
un petit peu parce que lorsque je paye
pour avoir un téléphone comme ça et que
j'utilise la logique la solution j'ai
pas envie que derrière ça il me coucher
leur pub en fait moi j'aime beaucoup le
concept je vous le redis une fois de
plus je trouve que l'idée de l'action'
cam intégré sur un smartphone comme ça
qui est complètement waterproof qui est
vraiment résistants c'est une super idée
par contre je pense qu'à vraiment des
points à améliorer déjà il faudrait
rendre le logiciel plus simple plus
intuitif pouvoir mélanger les plans
pouvoir naviguer plus facilement faire
un truc qui soit beaucoup plus
performant et bien ça je pense que c'est
un point de quoi je l'espère qui va être
améliorée par kroos cole en tout cas
gros score c'est vraiment un truc
important à modifier ça à mon avis
améliorer l'expérience utilisateur sur
le logiciel
parce que là dessus franchement j'ai pas
envie de faire des montages je trouve
que c'est pas forcément simple alors il
ya quelques petits bugs
je pense qu'ils vont être corrigée
rapidement mais pour moi l'expérience
utilisateur n est pas assez poussé en
tant que monteur en tant qu'utilisateur
en tout cas moi ce que je veux c'est
pouvoir déplacer mes plans elle
facilement brand content allez à droite
à gauche
tak tak modifié pour mettre la musique
facilement même pouvoir un ami tu l'a
coupée par endroits ça c'est vraiment le
truc que je veux faire et j'ai pas envie
d'aller galéré avec mon smartphone à
faire d'autant plus qu'il existe des
applications payantes mais qui
permettront de le faire plus facilement
il faut vraiment progresser là-dessus et
c'est un petit peu le point de regret
aujourd'hui sur ce smartphone parce que
je trouve vraiment hyper séduisant
accessoires il ya tout ce que je
trouvais assez marrant
c'était celui-là la selphy stick alors
ça va super héros tout ça c'est un style
tout simplement ça marche avec explique
d'exqi league c'est un petit sa semaine
aimanté que vous avez rien du smartphone
et contresens accessoires alors je
trouve ça franchement cool je trouve ça
franchement bien mais pour ça je suis
pas hyper pratique je voulais le prendre
en faisant du vélo à new york et je me
suis dit north pas une bonne idée parce
que voyez le problème ça tombe
immédiatement et là ça pardonne pas donc
ce que je regrette là dessus parce
qu'ils aient bien déjà c'est que lorsque
vous prenez comme ça voilà vous le monte
fait une photo par contre pas de
mouvements rien sinon ça tombe
immédiatement et ça il
un peu flipper donc il aurait fallu un
système plutôt comme on a sur la
poitrine qui va se refermer qui va le
bloquer pour que je puisse prendre le
sac ristic le prendre à la main à une
film est comme ça enfin de faire de la
bécane faire ce que je veux vous faire
du vélo voilà ça c'est un truc je pense
qu'il manque un peu l'accessoire il
faudrait encore un peu plus loin pas
pour aller faire jusqu'à que photos des
selles fille j'aurais ou c'est moi je
suis en scène filmée gens vraiment côté
actions icade
quand on va être la seule gamme il faut
aller dans l'action icade et sa
typiquement pour moi c'est pas
l'absorber chalgham sa d'accessoires
s'est débarrassé de lui comme tout comme
n'importe quel parent à celle ci en fait
je vous ai passé un petit peu toutes les
questions d'autonomie toutes les
questions d'utilisation du smartphone un
peu classique parce que ça va autrement
des smartphones de crosse coll je trouve
qu'il est bien l'autonomie je trouvais
droit très rapidement beaucoup l'espace
utilisateur je trouve bien le smartphone
est bien cros colle à savoir faire
maîtrisé là dessus c'est vraiment bien
la vraie nouveauté là dessus c'est
l'action de cannes c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très prometteur
je trouve que cros cole va vraiment se
mettre sur un segment là dessus qu'ils
aient pas encore exploité c'est vraiment
bien alors qu'il ya beaucoup de
smartphones comme saxon des oueds
smartphones résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière fait pour le travail est là
pour kate à pied d'or il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises si l'autre il ya beaucoup
de monde sans le marché l'idée
d'intégrer la chaîne calmes c'est
vraiment une excellente idée par contre
derrière il faut améliorer encore un
petit peu la version logicielle le
rendent encore plus stabilisée on est
sur un smartphone qui vous quand même
sept sont et des brouettes ont les dents
dans ce tarif là à peu près le fait
d'avoir filmé qu'à 30 images par seconde
c'est aussi un petit peu mais petit peu
embêtant je voudrais au moins du 60
images par seconde grand minimum et
après je vous dis là toute la partie
logicielle qu'il faut vraiment venir
améliorer pour améliorer l'expérience
utilisateur et s'il vous plaît cros cole
faites moi plaisir
enlevez moi cet écran de sang avec la
publicité cros colette parce que je vais
acheter un smartphone je vais l'acheter
un certain prix j'ai pas envie que
derrière il ya la plus grosse cole qui
se baladent sur tous les réseaux sociaux
je comprends c'est effectivement le
meilleur moyen de faire connaître ces
outils mais j'ai pas envie j'ai pas
envie et pour moi c'est un franc et je
me sens que c'est comme un watermark
condat sur les logiciels payants soit
quelle eau avec une version gratuite qui
est un peu limité on a le water marc
leiba j'ai l'impression qu'à la fin
celle watermark et ça m'embête parce que
j'ai quand même payer relativement cher
voilà tu peux le point de détail donc
l'absolu si vous voulez un smartphone
avec une action car je trouve que dire
le tracker x4 est très bien mais je
pense que cros cole peut aller encore
plus loin pour sortir un logiciel encore
meilleur smartphone encore meilleur avec
eux
sam kd encore meilleur une meilleure
expérience utilisateur et à mon avis à
ce moment là ce sera juste parfait dites
moi ce que vous pensez de ce smartphone
en commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
vous acheter un smartphone résistants
hyper étanche hyper solide avec une
action comme ça est ce que pour vous ça
a un sens est-ce quelque chose qui
pourrait vous plaire
vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire je vous invite à consulter
aussi des autres listes
si plein de produits plein de nouveautés
plus à vous montrer donc ma playlist sur
les smartphones soit aux objets
connectés
il ya plein de trucs hyper cool d'ici là
soyez sages prenez soin de vous et je
vous embrasse
ciao